Trump then suggests that China infected  the U.S with covid  to punish us because of the tariffs that  Trump put on China which of course Trump  still doesn't understand are actually  paid by American companies the American  companies pay the tariffs when they  import Chinese Goods we save many  Industries we took in hundreds of  billions of dollars in tariffs and taxes  from China they did not like me too much  that's why a lot of people said I wonder  why covet came here I wonder why that's  another it's another conspiracy theory  the reason covet came here I mean okay  fine it started in China  and then it went to Italy and then it  went to London and that okay eventually  it got here it was sent by China through  many other countries as punishment for  tariffs which our own companies paid  it's economics guys don't you understand  what's so confusing about that